[Music]
[Applause]
Hello friends and our beloved Su TV
family welcome to I'd like to know our
Bible question and answer program well
we get the chance the opportunity to
look at and answer your questions from
the word of God and we're so thankful
for this program because it gives us an
opportunity to go to the word of God
something we like to do but it also lets
us know what's on your mind what's on
your heart and those questions that you
have that will assist you in your walk
with Jesus Christ my name is CA Murray
and I'm in the company of Pastor Steven
bore who is the president and founder of
this wonderful Ministry this God bless
Ministry Secrets unsealed um Pastor good
to have you here and always good to work
with you it's always a pleasure working
with you CA I appreciate the compliment
and I like your time oh thank
you likewise praise the lord we we know
we have fun at this ministry the rumors
are true we actually do like each other
in fact we love each other in Jesus name
and that comes out as we study the word
of God
together we have to make you this
promise that we will get to your
questions uh some people sometimes get a
little upset because they don't get
their questions answered the weak that
they send them in uh we don't always get
to them right away but we will get to
them our pile is large and growing which
is a good problem to have it means that
a lot of people are listening and a lot
of people are responding so we promise
we will get to your questions and when
we do we will answer them from the word
of God now if you send in a question and
you don't hear the answer it may be for
a number of reasons one of them may be
that we've answered it on a previous
program uh so we don't get a chance to
reans or to revisit the that question
suffice it to say all questions will be
answered maybe not on air particularly
if it's a repeat question we'll have
that question answered to you uh by
email or some other means but every
question will be answered none falls to
the floor none skips our notice or our
mind we will take care of those
questions and we promise you from the
word of God if you have a question we
would like you we implore you to write
to us at TV atom tv.org
that's tvom tv.org and again we promise
we'll get to your questions as soon as
we can my pastor my friend would you
lead us in prayer and then we'll launch
right out into our questions let's pray
Father in Heaven as we begin this
program we realize that our knowledge is
so limited so we implore the presence of
your Holy Spirit give us clear thoughts
give us clear words and bless everyone
who is watching this program we pray in
Jesus name amen amen and amen you know
Pastor the more we study the more we
learn we realize there's so much more to
learn uh there's so much more that we
don't know and each time you go to the
word of God uh the Sanctified mind
something new to sort of ruminate on
because there's just so much to study
and so we learned indeed on this program
you know it's a real blessing to get the
questions because it sharpens our
knowledge indeed it does well said all
right our first question comes to us
from Sandra Brown hello
Sandra this question is asking after his
resurrection where was Jesus between the
time he rose and when Mary encountered
him in the garden was he resurrecting
that special group that lay in the field
uh at his death who were the first
fruits and were with him uh to be his
Witnesses in Jerusalem uh God bless and
thank you this is Sandra Brown who is a
doctor of education so we don't know
exactly where you are writing us from
Sandra but thank you for writing and uh
we will try to uh work our way through
this I think we want Pastor Matthew
27 uh she's referring to and we can pick
it
up uh verse 51 or 52 I guess 51 would
help us a little bit better and go down
to maybe in Cent to
53 um okay Matthew 27 MH 51 through
53 I'm reading from The New American
Standard Bible M it says and behold the
veil of the temple was torn in two from
top to bottom and the Earth Shook and
the Rocks were split and the tombs were
opened and many bodies of the Saints who
had fall and asleep were raised and
coming out of their tombs after his
resurrection they entered the holy city
and appeared to
many amen and amen I want to read just a
paragraph or so from uh desar ages that
covers the same
uh event uh and get some counsel from
Ellen White here and then we can we can
kick around some some ideas as Christ
arose he brought from the grave a
multitude of captives the earthquake at
his death had rent open their graves and
when he arose they came forth with him
they were those who had been C- laborers
with God and who at the cost of their
lives had borne their testimony to the
truth now they were to be Witnesses for
him who had raised them from the dead
just one a couple mindes more during his
ministry Jesus had raised the Dead dead
to life and had raised the sons of the
Widow of the son rather of the Widow of
name and the ruler's daughter and
Lazarus but these were not clothed with
immortality after they were raised they
were still subject to death but those
who came forth from the grave at
Christ's Resurrection were raised to
everlasting life they ascended with him
as trophies of his victory over death
and the grave these said Christ are no
longer captives of Satan I have redeemed
them I have bought them I have brought
them from the grave as the first fruits
of my power to be with me where I am
never more to see death or experience
sorrow yeah you know when you read the
Bible passage uh this group is
enshrouded in mystery mhm um you know
who were they the text is does say it
does not say how many were there it
doesn't say doesn't say when did they
live it doesn't say how did they die
does not we're not told no did they
resurrect with glorified bodies or with
their mortal bodies the text doesn't
tell us but praise the Lord that we have
the spirit of Prophecy amen and uh the
text that you just read has several
answers to the questions that I proposed
first of all we are told that they were
a multitude yes Ellen White says it was
a multitude so it was a whole big group
of people also we notice that they uh
were captives of the grave of course
they came forth from the grave when he
came forth yes from the grave MH um they
were
Martyrs because because she says that
they had been collabor with God who at
the cost of their lives had borne
testimony to the truth yes now there's
another statement as well that uh we
find in the book early writings page 184
which fills in some more blanks it says
those favored risen Saints came forth
glorified amen so now we know that they
that they came forth with their Immortal
corruptible bodies indeed uh they were
chosen and holy ones of every
age from creation down even to the days
of Christ now that's important we need
to put a little pin right there so these
are going back to to the days of of of
the antal luian days these are from
creation so this this is a big this's
not a couple people in the corner
someplace a big number of people that
Christ and uh the graves are open those
some of those people have been dead for
centuries so they had you know the
natural process of Decay had taken place
so A great miracle took place when when
when Christ came uh uh and and and those
graves are open and not people just dead
a couple years years or a couple months
people have been dead for centuries yeah
and uh you know a significant point I
think here is it says that they were
holy ones of every age from creation
down to the days of Christ I like that
and they were Martyrs I like that yes so
I would assume that probably Abel the
first
martyr around creation time yes was
among that group it would not do
violence to the text to to assume that I
and we know that Adam was more than
twice as tall as the men this day and
age indeed so can you imagine uh what it
would have been like for Abel because
it's from creation whether it was Abel
or not you know it doesn't make any
difference because really uh the height
of the men was more than twice as tall
um can you imagine someone appearing to
someone in Jerusalem saying hi I am Abel
and I'm here to witness that Jesus
Christ has resurrected from the dead I
like the way your mind works I'm
thinking the same thing as some 12 foot
tall guy comes you got to believe in
that yeah yeah that's that's preaching
the the resurrection of Christ that's a
powerful powerful witness and and she
says they were they went throughout the
city and they proclaimed Christ so
summarizing they were captives in the
grave they were
Saints they were not a handful but a
multitude
they came out of their graves when Jesus
resurrected they received their
glorified bodies they were people who
lived from creation to the days of
Christ they bore testimony to the truth
that is to Jesus they died as Martyrs
for bearing witness to the truth they
went into the City and testified that
Jesus had resurrected and that they were
the
proof and they ascended to Heaven 40
days after the resurrection when Jes
ascended to Heaven yes they were around
a long time they were the first fruits
of the day of Pentecost on the day of
Pentecost there were first fruits first
fruits Jesus resurrected uh in the Feast
of first fruits um on on Sunday morning
yes but then the group that resurrected
with him he presented as trophies in
heaven 40 days later when he ascended to
Heaven powerful powerful powerful
powerful testimony so in so in the
question was he resurrecting that
special group that lay in the field at
his death who were the first fruits and
were to be his Witnesses in Jerusalem
that's very conceivable because uh I
assume that Jesus probably told them you
know go into the City and and tell
everyone that uh the Messiah has
resurrected from the dead yes U you know
I don't think that they would uh
resurrect and then suddenly uh you know
say oh let's go witness that Jesus
resurrected obviously they knew that
Jesus had resurrected yes yes they got
the orders from him um give me the the
reference for for Sandra uh in that um
early writings page 184 184 of early
writings because this Desire of Ages
reference was uh 786 uh paragraph two so
they compliment each other indeed they
do they really really do so Sandra good
question it it it it allowed me and
pastor bour and we studied separately
but we we ran into the same material uh
to go back and sort of because this is
refreshing this is something that
encourages you encourages us to talk
about the resurrection of Christ and
what what happened on that faithful
morning that fantastic Miracle filled
morning when Christ Rose in the grave
and we don't know hundreds thousands
hundreds of thousands we don't know how
many Rose with him a multitude uh to be
his first Witnesses amen first
Ambassador ambassadors well done and
very good thank you Pastor uh for that
um the next is from Claire who is from
Southern California uh dear Pastor bore
and and staff um Revelation 211 reads as
follows and I saw a new Heaven and a new
Earth for the first Heaven and the first
Earth had passed away and there were no
longer any Seas actually it is C without
the S um so having quoted that verse uh
now comes the questions um if all the
seas are to disappear in the earth made
new what will happen to all the dolphins
whales fishes and other amazing
creatures that are in the ocean and
require an a an ocean environment to
survive um are there biblical answers or
in the writing of Ellen White um and of
course it's the rest is an elaboration
she she wants to know if the Seas go
what happens to the sea creatures
basically um my hope is that there are
biblical answers available however if
you do not uh perhaps God perhaps God
needs more land mass to accommodate the
large population of angels and humans
that will have the new Earth so she's
worried about the Seas and she's worried
about the sea creatures what help can we
give
her well uh the bottom line is that
according to the Book of
Revelation compared with Jeremiah
chapter
4 uh what's going to happen with the
plagues is the plagues are going to
return the Earth to the condition it was
in before creation weak uh
Jeremiah 4:23 says that Jeremiah beheld
the Earth and it was without form and
void which is the condition of the earth
uh at the very beginning before the
beginning of creation week uh now uh one
of the things that's going to take place
as a result of the plagues uh in
Revelation chapter
16 it describes uh the first Angel and
then it goes into the second Angel uh
first Angel it speaks about a malignant
soar for those who had received the mar
beast and who worshiped His Image and
then you have the second Angel pouring
out his plague and it says into the
sea and it became like like the blood of
a dead man and every living thing in the
sea died yes yes so in other words uh
the second plague is going to wipe out
all Marine creatures all marine life now
there's there's a very important detail
and that is that when God makes a new
heavens and a new Earth he is going to
restore
what existed at the beginning mhm in
other words he's going to undo what the
plagues did yes uh the first day he's
going to he's going to say let there be
light the second day the firmament the
third day you know all the vegetation
that was burned up by the fourth plague
uh he's going to once again establish
all of the um all of the vegetation he's
going to place the sun moon in stars in
their locations where they can benefit
Earth he's going to also uh create the
birds and the fish which he created on
the on the fifth day and he's going to
create all the land creatures and then
of course he doesn't have to create the
redeemed because the redeemed are
already there as the witnesses uh so uh
basically what God is going to do he's
going to restore that which existed at
the beginning now there's a very
important point and that is that um
there were not huge bodies of water when
God created this world yes Ellen White
speaks about maybe lakes and you know
large large bodies of water but but the
the reason why the planet is covered
mostly with water is because of the
flood because of the flood and uh and so
it's an effect of the effect of the
curse MH uh because the flood was a
cursed on the earth so in the earth made
new you're not going to have these huge
uh these huge bodies of water and just a
small percentage of dry land yes uh
another point is that um another way of
looking at this when it says that
there's no sea uh it can be referring to
the literal sea but it could also be
referring to uh the wicked who tried to
destroy the righteous who are compared
yes to the sea to the Sea yes and maybe
we can read if you could read Isaiah
1712 and 13 got it right here um Isaiah
1712 and 13 that's another way of
explaining it I prefer to believe that
there's not going to be
huge bodies of water I I like them both
and and and and if you had not gone
there and I knew you were I was going to
chime in with that but I like the idea
uh the notion or the idea the
understanding that the the deep ocean
trenches and the things that we see now
were not part of the original creation
they were part of the upheaval that came
at the at the at the Deluge at the at
the flood and the Earth turning upside
down so uh we're not going to go back to
that we're going to go back to the
original creation that does not have
that so we're in in Isaiah 17 12 and 13
and 12 and
13 it compares the the wicked wanting to
destroy God's people with the waves of
the sea woe to the multitude of many
people who make a noise like the Roar of
the Seas and to the rushing of Nations
that make a rushing like the rushing of
Mighty Waters and verse 13 the Nations
will rush like the rushing of many
Waters but God will rebuke them and they
will flee far away away and be chased
like the chaff of the mountains before
the wind like a rolling thing before the
Whirlwind uh then behold at even tide
even tide trouble and before the morning
he is no more this is the portion of
those who plunder us and the lot of
those who rob us so so in other words
the sea can represent the multitudes of
Nations that wanted to destroy God's
people yes and uh in that sense there
will no longer be that kind of sea that
kind of sea it could also refer to the
literal sea you're not going to have the
large bodies of waters that you had that
you have as a result of sin yeah through
trust in God my pastor we believe that
everything on the other side of this
cleansing of the Earth is going to be
better than what we have now amen so we
we can trust in God who will Who will
save us that he will create a perfect
pristine world we will lose nothing in
their translation um and that which is
now will not be then but that which will
be then will be better than what we have
now amen amen we praise the Lord for
that abely right yeah but but it it's
good her her question is answered really
in the in in that plague as as you go
back to uh Revelation chapter 16 uh all
living flesh is already will in the sea
will already be dead uh by the end of
the plague so well done very very good
question and very good so thank you very
much uh Claire from Southern
California uh okay I'm looking at the
clock on the wall we got time maybe to
get one more Vincent he is calling or
rather writing to us from Kenya or Kenya
as they say I borrowed I borrowed from a
bank whereby my job is the security for
the loan I will take seven it will take
rather seven years for it to be settled
my question is if we enter the time of
no buying no selling before I complete
paying can I inherit the Kingdom loans
are always insured if I decide to quit
employment before the loan payment is
over and leave it to the insurance to
pay is that a moral uh thing for a
Christian okay we've got a bunch of
things here
um I should start by using a quote that
uh my teacher who taught us Life of
Christ and way back in college said to
us no Devi ation from strict inte
Integrity you meet God's approval in
other words when you enter into any
contract any loan any borrowing anything
like that you ought to enter into that
with the full intention of meeting the
stipulations of the contract amen and as
a Christian carrying the name of Christ
of following
through my Reckoning says the time of
trouble and the time of no buying and
selling will take care of itself you
don't order your life now thinking about
a time of trouble when it
comes you make a contract you honor the
contract as a child of God because you
are representing God and you intend when
you sign on the line to fulfill the
obligations that you have contracted to
fulfill amen if something happens if the
world comes to an end if Christ comes
tomorrow well then all bets are off I
mean things change but you don't you
don't enter into a contract uh with that
in mind you enter into a
contract expecting to fulfill the
obligations pursuant to that contract
yeah uh I'd like to read a verse from
Psalm 37 verse 21 says the wicked
borrows and does not pay back
yes but the righteous is gracious and
gives so the righteous don't act like
the Wicked the wicked borrow and then
they they don't pay back what they
borrowed mhm um you know it's like
individuals these days who max out their
credit
card and they can't pay and so they
contract with the company that will that
will negotiate with the credit card
company to reduce it to practically
nothing yes that's dishonest it is
because you're
defrauding the stores that you bought
from sure you and the insurance the
insurance which probably is is going to
pay for the difference is actually
paying for your for your loan mhm and so
uh you you should not max out your
credit card and it's not this specific
case but it's similar yes and then and
then say well I can't pay so let's have
this company settle with uh for pennies
on the dollar yes with the company that
I actually uh purchased from so it's a
very similar case um
and by the way the best is not to get
into debt yes yes sound it like the
plague uh and do the try to live as best
you can inside the means um I don't
remember where I heard this I don't know
Spirit prophecy um it's not how much you
make it's what you do with what you get
you know it's how you spend your money
wisely you know uh Micah 68 here show
the old man what is good what do the
Lord require of Thee the first thing out
of out uh in the next verse is do justly
be just be fair be honest honest if you
go to work for for uh X number of hours
then then when you get your pay make
that commented with what what what
you're doing you've got to be honest in
all that we're doing because we are
carrying the name of Christ we are
Christ ambassadors and as Christ
embassadors it is your job to lift up
the name of Jesus and be correct in all
you do so that you rightly represent the
Lord whom you serve and uh uh you're
fitting Yourself by your conduct here on
Earth for eternal life with him amen if
I could just mention very quickly here
we at the very end some Bible verses
that people can look up yes 2 Kings 4:7
Romans 4:4 Exodus
22:14 and Proverbs 61 through 5
1115 and 1718 all address this specific
question all righty well done well our
time has fast lift into eternity allow
me in closing to wish you Grace and
peace through our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ we'll see you again next time God
bless
[Music]